hi my name is Jorge Ramirez I'm from
University a national image in Colombia
I will be giving a talk about how we use
Wolfram language to produce problem
sheets and manage large mathematics
courses
my name is Jorge Ramirez a mom I'm a
professor mathematics at the University
at Nacional de Colombia in Medellin I do
Mathematica user for the last I don't
know 15 18 years I do
sarcastic processes modeling in the
Natural Sciences but I'm also an
educator and I'm going to show you here
some things interesting maybe novel
things novel ways of using the Wolfram
language in education you might
appreciate it so first a little bit of
this is where I live South America
that's Colombia and that's a map over
campus so my university it's a somewhat
big in New York City and it has a it's
mostly an engineering school so we have
a lot of students in engineering and I'm
part of the math department so they're
what we do is the math department
teaches classes the math classes to all
the engineering students so the as a
result we have this the following
problem we have what we call
coordinating classes so like me I am the
coordinator of the differential calculus
class now the differential calculus
class is 23 sections with 23 from
professors and a total of 1702 and say
1800 students take in the same class
during one given semester and they have
recitations and there have you know TAS
and so on but the important thing is a
four we have the system to ensure
quality that we all evaluate the same
simultaneously all the students so they
are they have to take all the same tests
even though they go to different classes
they have different professors the
curriculum is the same and we evaluate
them simultaneously with the same
problems so we need to keep on the
challenge then is to give resources and
opportunities for students in order to
so they all have can uniformly study and
prepare for the same
okay and we do that in you know throw
ways so we use as as our software of
choice the university you know uses we
use Moodle so this is a this is our
website so you have all the standard
stuff and here we have I'll tell you
what this is this is we do use
Mathematica in the classroom so what I'm
showing you here is things like this is
a here's a CDF about you know
exponential functions and you know it
has the usual stuff and the way I use
this and the way I have TAS used this is
that we have this in the classroom
during lectures right next to blackboard
and we teach and we do interactive
calculations and we do we use the CDF as
both in class to guide our lectures but
also a supplemental interactive material
for students so they can you know take
home and print or you know play with it
and so on okay
so we do do that which is kind of a
wonderful yet standard way of using
Mathematica in the classroom but I want
to show you something different okay so
the year that we have this if you if
you're a math teacher you have this
problem of you know assigning math
problems right and then you know they
have to have we have to have problem
sheets for all our students and the
problem sheets have to be you know
relevant enough and they have to prepare
them in a system in their study process
so they can you know not fail exam now
how do you so you have this bunch of
problems you've written all your life
and you want to assign them and you know
write them up so the students can try to
solve them and this those problems are
used for problem sheets
practice exams presentation activities
and exams okay so we came up with this
idea that maybe will be great to
streamline that process somehow so
show you our solution to this it's a
math problem database and it has two
components it has we use latex so it has
a folder of problem statements I'm going
to show you this is it you can see my
this is just my file so you see this is
the our database and each of these
folders has a little snippet of latex
code so like here's a here's a little
problem it has this is some late some
late a code and in this particular
problem as you know it has something but
it also has like many of them he has an
associated figure right so database of
problem is just a bunch of folders in
each folder you have a little bit of
later code that is you know and whatever
PDF or any other associated material
with a later code in it okay so this is
our database so that's the first
component of a database it is all these
folders is my problem database each each
one of these folders has it has a
different problem there's like a
thousand of them now now the second part
of the database is very interesting okay
oh sorry to tell you something else
each problem has this database so it has
fields so there's three fields that
identify each problem the one is subject
so which subject is this limit is the
functional differential equations is
these exponential functions there one is
difficulty so a number from 1 to 10 tell
me how difficult this problem is the
third one is type what type of problem
is the word problem is this a conceptual
problem it's a calculation role so
there's three fields and there's an
order field that is important because
many problems have common statements for
example solve the following limit or
find or graph the following function so
you have I don't want to have you I'll
show you what I mean by that so common
statements it's one of the fields that
are problem they have so that's those
are
my my fields in each problem and the
other part of my database is very
interesting because what it is is the
pro is a solution sheet a solution
manual I'll show you one of them here's
here here are all my solution manuals so
they were just written by TAS here's a
solution manual the solution manual is
written it as a mathematical notebook so
here's the solution the solution for
problem 498 and sometimes it's text
sometimes is just a calculation solution
495 is just a calculation sometimes it's
just it sometimes it has you know plots
and it has some text here company ways
it's a solution right it's a solution to
the problem sometimes it's just a single
line likes a computer limit but it's
just a full notebook with a random
collection of problems that were sold by
this particular person out of my
database right okay so those those are
the components of my database a bunch of
folders and problems each problem has
some fields and then a bunch of
notebooks in random order without with
sections covering all the solutions of
my problems okay now okay what do we do
with that so here's what we do so I have
at least little package it doesn't have
my many functions but what I'm going to
do now here is I'm going to create my
database here's what it's doing right
now it's going through all the folders
in late ik extracting all the tech and
creating a data set object very
conveniently so I can manage that and
then I save it as an MX so I have to I
only had to do this once or whatever
whenever I update my folders I just do
this and then I read the thousand
problems or so and it created this data
data set object that has you know the
number of the problem the subject
difficult to type whatever it has a
common statement or not the statement of
the problem and it has whether it has
figures or not and it has in which file
do I have the solution right that's my
database and if the database
dataset object retrieving that saving
that as an MX file is very easy to
retrieve in that it's instantaneous okay
oh that MX file on that database oh
here's an ordered another little piece
of thing I need this is the this is the
list of common statement so there's
nineteen possible common statements say
one of them says compute the following
limit or a very important one is is this
true or false right so those are our
common statements that I have I have
only nineteen of them if I want to add
more this just add more now that I have
a database I can make a query right so
here's a query in which I want to select
let's see all problems I want to select
25 random samples of problems of
subjects 4 5 or 6 of difficulty between
4 & 7
okay so here's the well there's a 25
problems there they're sorted in a
rational way so they're sorted by their
group by common statement say if there's
any common statements and they're sorted
by subject right and within them they're
sorted by the difficulty or type I
remember well here's a this is actually
a collection of databases data set
subject that I get out of that now now
that I selected my problems there's
there's a cool step I want to create a
tech file that has I want to create a
PDF file with those problems so what
does that entail that entails that I I
have to take a preamble paste it I had
to create a new file take a preamble
paste it then look for all the problems
or pasting them in the right order and
respecting common statements so they say
the to take the five or six through or
four that were selected put them as an
item we're gonna enumerate environment
put the correct statement on top of it
and also if I find any problem that has
a PDF I'll attach the way I had to
retrieve the PDF file and put in the
same folder as right that's what that's
what it entails that's what it is so
let's do that so that is this function
so if you see
this is my folder there's no test here
there's no folder I'm not gonna cheat
this is like magic so I'm gonna call
this function that creates text and it's
gonna create put everything a new folder
called test right so let's just run it
and that's actually instantaneous so now
there's a test folder here that has a
tech file and all the PDF that were
select all the PDF that were selected
right so that packed file is well that
is a stand-alone tech violent it's gonna
write open up with whatever it is that
you open up tech files here's the
preamble and here are the tell all the
problems so here's a problem here's
here's a problem right there has a
collection of all the problems and this
should compile and that's the PDF so a
PDF has some features there nice so it
has the correct the graphics each
problem has an identifier with the
number so the first problem in this
particular PDF is number four zero four
seven one it has a little triangle there
that tells the student which the
difficulty of the problem and without an
identifier he can just go and then get
the solution well it is what it is right
it's just all the problems whatever
here's a problem here's a common
statement right there's a common
statement and were selected for problems
that have that common statement so
they're correctly labeled what is it
supposed to be and so okay great so I
had now a problem sheet that was
randomly selected from my database all
right what about the solution well then
you create the solution now creating the
solution it tells something something
similar about manipulating notebooks
because they I have to get all my
problem list and mine the notebook files
and get all the sections out and put
them and you can actually seal this live
because there's all this notebook
manipulation functions actually work so
that there is is this building live all
the the pouring pasting all the sections
with the right and then it disappears
and then I can open it up again and then
that it's
in my folder it now it has this MB file
that has all the solutions so you just
retrieve the solutions from the data
from the whatever right and so that's a
product almost that's almost a problem
because um I'll show you later the
things I don't know how to do and so
maybe you can help me okay but I want to
show you two further applications of
this um that we use in my school is this
one is this so we have recitations right
and there's 33 recitation sessions and
in each recitation like just like this
sighs and then the students pair up and
they solve an easy problem now that
problem comes out of the database but
it's very important they're there since
there's 33 sections of recitations each
presentation has to have a slightly
different problems so here's um so
here's a PDF we generate aromatically in
which there's actually 33 PDFs here and
each PDF each page has the section
number has the name of the TA has the an
has slightly different values of these
parameters for the particular problem so
we randomized are over given set each
problem specifies which which parameters
you can randomize and on which range and
then we just produce automatically this
set of PDFs or is that this is a say 4
and 6.5 and in this one is four and five
point five right it's the same and it
has the different TA and a different
section where it is in the time that's
one application something a little bit
more more sophisticated is the following
is four exams so we have 1700 students
taking the same exam at the same time
that takes most of our campus actually
and you know it it's something like
something like around 50 classroom for
those students and if they were talk
about Columbia right so is there
cheating so we're very careful about
cheating right and so there's a
couple things you need to do and we do
this automatically so a couple of cool
things here I'll show you we this is
what the proctor in person this is all
generator automatically this is what the
proctor gets the proctor get some we
take we go to every classroom we will
retrieve the geometry of the classroom
so how many rows and and to each seat we
associate a number and this number is
corresponds to an exam and the exam is
automatically this is this is an exam so
if you notice this is a salmon number
one out of 17 hundred that automatically
has the name of the student is
identification and where it's going to
take the exam and it has the problems
from the database so we pasted the
problems from the database they're the
appropriate problems and it has it has a
bunch of labels in particular it has
this label because there's actually four
four versions of the exam because you
get exam subject ABCD ABCD or whatever
is that according to the geometry of the
classroom we we we decide is the better
way so that's another application and
this exams are then you can do a bunch
of them you see all these labels here
there are a labeling system that our law
allows us to never lose an exam so I
give the exams according to a first
label I collect them in organizing
according to the second label I grade
them according to a third label and I
punch integrate according to the fourth
label yeah when you have 1700 exams with
40 people grading them you don't want to
loosen a single exam so that's it has
helped with you have helped us greatly
never lose second exam again okay I want
to show you I'm about to finish but uh I
want to show you something I don't know
how to do and I would really like to
know what I do I would like its student
to go somewhere online hopefully Moodle
Moodle and fill out a form like this so
here's here's what I will really love I
will love
student to say oh I want give me please
I don't know 34 problems between
difficulty 3 and 7 of the subjects 5 and
6 and and I wanted to put all the folder
number on the folder named Jorge so I
want somewhere to put a form online
where a student can do that that part is
easy I think they submit then somehow my
database has to be in that thing and now
it's running so this is created
automatically and then the student can
click there's a very important extra
step I had no idea do I would like
Mathematica to come to tell latex to
compile my elective code so compile
automatically create a PDF create a
notebook create a notebook and it should
be right here maybe it said you couldn't
do it why well create a create a PDF
file create the notebook and then
download all automatically and that the
reason I want to do that is that um it's
not to save my time it's what I really
like what I really like is to turn this
into a an assistant system learning
system in which a student can can go say
ok it's 4:00 in the afternoon or a
Monday I would like to study math and
then you go in ok myself my exam is some
limits okay
can you please give me 10 practice
problems of limits in easy ones and then
you get them and then since I get the
solution manual the student can then get
feedback it's not about grading it's
about assisting study the sooner I get
feedback and based on that feedback I
can then suggest the next 10 problems
and so on and then assist the student
through his here or her study right
until he is able to complete the harder
problems or the relevant roles for the
particular test so that's the that's the
the the dream which is pretty far away
from but that's where we're trying to go
with this is a system of personalized
study and maybe hope
it can be smart in use artificial
intelligence - okay what was - Stern
that did this correctly what should be
or her but what should she be able to do
the next so that's that's the goal and I
I think that's all I have to show you if
you have any questions